I have to stop being apologetic about it
women want strong men and men want
feminine women they want their women to
be women and women want their men to be
men okay let's just say it all right
there's this collapse of the sexist into
kind of this uniform
totalitarian egalitarianism because
that's what it becomes it's death to the
soul it's even more complex than what
you're saying because the desire that
men have for women to be feminine the
desire that women want men to be
masculine because there's this
totalitarian egalitarian you know Fusion
of everything it also creates strange
parasitic extreme male figures and so
what you end up having is you have a
weird parasitic version of of hyper
masculinity which becomes popular and
things like gangster rap or you know 50
Shades of Gray all these images violent
dangerous men and then you have these
insane kind of horror almost like
prostitute images of hyper feminine
broken down images and they become
extremely popular so on the one hand you
have this idea that we ought to be the
same and then you have these figures
that look like caricature of a
caricature of a caricature of what a man
and a woman is yeah it becomes freakish
the distortions become freakish because
if everything is melded together it's
the only thing that you can see yeah
it's the only indication of of
Distinction left which still conversely
affirms that the fundamental distinction
the binary is true
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
so hello everybody I am very happy and
honored to be here with Father Hans
Jacobs I have known father Hans for
several years uh I actually have a very
uh powerful moment where he prayed for
me several years ago at the very outset
of my speaking engagement and I was very
uh I was very encouraged and touched by
his the work that he's doing and I've
seen that he's doing all this amazing
work with young men
he is a priest at the Saint Peter's
Church Orthodox St Peter's Church
Orthodox uh in Florida he is also the
leader of the saint paisio's Brotherhood
which is a movement that is looking to
help young men to find their way to find
a positive and healthy masculinity in
their lives but in the church as well
and so father Hans thank you for talking
to me yeah my pleasure Jonathan's great
to be here it's good to see you again
too yeah it's good to see you so father
Hans tell me a little bit about what you
see as the situation let's say in terms
of masculinity in the society but in the
church as well and also what it is that
you what you see as a as a way out or as
a way forward
um it it came out of a personal crisis
Jonathan which I won't go into detail
but basically I was brought to a place
and it's by the hand of God it really
was where
um you know I was an honest kind of a
cultural Warrior and I kind of was right
and then some events happened in my life
to really cause me to rethink that I
took three years I took three years and
it was a humbling experience but those
experiences are good and long story
short I prayed one day and I said Lord
what do you want me to do what am I
supposed to do
and quite literally he said open your
eyes
meanwhile some young men entered my life
and and
um I began to help them learned a lot
and the opening eyes moment was this
that there were guys falling off the
cliff they were falling into the fire
right and instead of me trying to change
you know the the culture politically and
and socially and all that you know
writing articles and all that I just
started dealing with these guys
one-on-one
and those are the people that God
brought into my life
and I began to see what the problems
really were and I began to learn how to
deal with them and I did that for about
five years and then I was invited by
Father Patrick Henry Reardon to speak at
a touchstone conference and I brought
some of this stuff together and I gave a
talk and after that talk it went on a
slow viral and these young men started
calling me up from all over the country
that's when I realized that that what I
had been given here it's a discovery but
but what I have been given to by the
Lord
um it was very powerful it was very very
powerful and and and men were healed by
it men were healed by it and it had a
lot to do but coming out of what I call
coming out of the Matrix okay and the
Matrix is really a cultural form is what
it is and uh
and even the gospel is reduced just to
propositions you and Jordan Peterson
talk about that a lot and it's very
effective it's very very effective and I
use a lot of what both of you come up
with because it's you've thought through
it and you you give me concise ways to
say it and I call it the Matrix
so the guys want to come out of the
Matrix you know boys want to become men
but they don't know how and the
masculinity in the culture is so
denigrated but so is the Christianity
it's just reduced to propositions is
what it is
which which you know on a I would say on
a psychological spiritual soul level
um it it it's basically behavior
modification and it doesn't work and we
need Soul transformation and that's the
beauty of Orthodoxy it's the the the
power of of of the Orthodox Faith but
really Christ and the transformation of
the soul and of the human person well
started bringing that forward and see
these men healed and it's I have to say
it's the most meaningful work I've ever
done in my life
that's what it is in a nutshell Jonathan
but what does it look like in terms of
the type of practices or the type of of
of work that you're doing with them
well it's a lot of one-on-one and a lot
over the phone and I talked to a lot of
guys I talked to probably three or four
guys every day
you know that adds up over the month
right I don't even look at my minutes
anymore but like I say I've got the uh
what is it the extended unlimited plan
right I got a good phone yeah but I grow
to love these guys and these guys really
take the council you know there's
something about the beauty of Truth and
it's this I mean truth has to be spoken
it has to be spoken and Truth enters the
world first through a word through what
is spoken
and and you know truth itself is
self-verifying
um there's nothing higher than the truth
okay the truth is the truth
and but there's a resonance in the soul
that occurs to the man who hears it and
is seeking truth
truth of course manifests itself
ultimately as Jesus Christ because he is
the truth and truth thus is ultimately
very personal so the transformation in
in the heart and the heart is the center
of the soul the transformation of the
man occurs deep on the inside
and and here you know the scriptures are
so beautiful because it is a seed
planted it is a seed planted and that
that seed germinates and grows and you
see the transformation in these men it's
just beautiful it's one of the most
beautiful things I've ever I've ever
seen and it it happens in a again and
again to see to see a person grow into
what I call their personal particularity
right to become a true Son of God and
then to become their own man because
those things work hand in hand they
don't work separately right and and it
it's it's really a wondrous thing it's
it's a recreation that that I'm
privileged to see with my own eyes
brings great meaning to life
and and and it posits them so one-on-one
initially a lot of encouragement and
just simple instruction but out of that
that's how it started but out of that I
realized that this problem is is is
really huge and that there are many men
many men who want a more solid
sense of their own masculinity and
there's no place to find it there really
is not and so this also presents a very
unique opportunity for the church and I
think the means by which the gospel will
be spread
um in our cultural particularity
all right every generation is different
every generation has its own problems so
out of that
out of that group the concept of the
Brotherhood
and which I just starred and two men
came to me and said we had to start this
and I I
I'm uh cautious now of committing myself
to things because I've had a lot of
false starts in my life and I realize
you know just don't fly off and do
something just because it's good it
sounds good and and uh I thought about
it for six months and prayed about it
and said yeah we have to do this and so
we started the Brotherhood and we're
building that out now again it's a
learning as you go operation but we're
getting there and it's getting some
traction and my goal is this is to build
brotherhoods all around the country
that's what I want to do that's my goal
because it's through Brotherhood it's
through Brotherhood that men find
themselves so so what I say now and I
say to lot is men learn how to become a
man from other men
and that requires Brotherhood and that
requires real authentic communion
between men because we draw our
masculinity from each other
and this fits perfectly with Orthodox
anthropology you know there is no such
thing as a single individual
and it ties into
um
and this is where I find your work so
helpful Sean it's Jonathan um it ties
into the very structure of the creation
you know there's a congruency between
the structure of the soul and the
structure of of creation and there's a
particular order to that but it's
ontological okay it's not a schematic
you know it's not a drawing of a
computer chip that you look at in this
great complexity it's not that it's it's
it's alive and the and the energy that
energy that that vivifies it all is Love
Is Love right and and this love itself
has character because it flows from God
and and the fathers teach us yes that
the characters virtue the cultivation of
virtue and the conservation of virtue is
actually what brings the structure was a
which is latent into life like looking
at an animation of a topographic map
then all of a sudden you know the
mountains form and The Valleys form and
you can see it in 3D that's what it's
like right and it just flows with this
beautiful
creative
benevolent energy which is actually
reveals to us the character of God the
beauty of the creation and the
fundamental goodness of man and you see
this and you know the guys that come in
just really beat down really really beat
down just defeated but there's something
in their soul that longs for this life
and again you start explaining it to
them and it resonates that's the truth
right that's how the truth Works in US
it begins it begins with language it
really begins with a language
but why wouldn't it be any other way
Jonathan because the world was created
by
speech right God said let there be light
and there was light and you know that
they um I'm getting a little excited
here I know this but what's so beautiful
about this is you know the power of that
primordial word that is replicated in
the preaching of the Gospel that is
because what it does it's not a new well
it is a new creation Paul says but it's
really the recapitulation of a fallen
creation towards the kingdom of God when
all things will be made whole
and it begins in the soul and and here
you know there's the same Maximus the
Confessor right man as the center of the
cosmos but that's what I discovered and
and so so you know the first issue is
always pornography self-abuse the sexual
stuff we're a sex obsessed Society but I
I see
that in in a materialist World okay in
philosophically okay and coming out of
materialism back into symbolism really
you talk about this a lot
you know in a materials world all you
have is sex it's the only material point
of transcendence because the sexual
desire is a unit of Desire ultimately in
the body it brings together Body Soul
and mind right it's a beautiful gift
from God but tremendously misused in our
day and age but if a person is looking
for Transcendence
but they're they're they're locked in
the shackles of materialism right then
the only way you can go the only way you
can find Transcendence is is through
sexuality and that really messes people
up
because it's such a powerful thing so
it's the reordering of that it's really
the reording of that and one of the
reasons I have success here with people
getting out of pornography and all the
attendant behaviors is is an Insight I
received and it was from Saint Maximus
the Confessor that that the foundation
of all desire is a desire for God and so
the healing from these these these
maladies or their their personal
maladies but they're in a sense you know
culturally determined because of the way
our culture is
um is really to redirect the desire to
redirect to the desire what's missing
here I'll tell you what's missing here
is that the the man's native and I'm
talking about men men a man's native
desire to create
is actually subverting of the sexual
desire which itself is a sexual desire
they get all mixed up together and the
man becomes defeated
and here here the beauty of of Orthodox
aesthetical discipline separate that
right and direct that creative desire
into productive work
right and the gratification that he's
seeking through through self-abuse and
behaviors like that is actually met by
Honest work with his hands
right and that's once a man experiences
that then he is on on the path to
Healing which is to say you know the the
the the the
vivification of the proper ordering and
structure of his soul I got way ahead on
my question but that's what I do no
that's correct father so maybe let's
start let me let's start with because I
think
one of the difficulties that we that men
have had especially is
that there's been a displacement about
what it is to be a man in many
directions so we have you know we have
the images of the the sports star or the
action hero that type of image is there
but then we also have the image of the
of the feminized man or the you know the
man who who who basically uh denies his
own masculinity what do you think like
how would you describe what it is to be
a Christian man what how does
Christianity preserve transform what
image of masculinity does it present
well I I you know we have models in the
lives of the Saints
okay and you see really different
personality types
in the lives of the Saints but I would
say that that fundamentally and this is
a little abstract it's a little abstract
but you know you help guys find us I
mean fundamentally the definition of
true masculinity is to to Define for
yourself who you are and what your
purpose in this world is now every man
desires that some men sublimate it any
man who is self-aware and and has some
measure of self-honesty okay that's the
central question that can only be
answered in communion with our creator
but how do we come in to communion with
our our creator it's through Brotherhood
it is through Brotherhood I mean every
Everything of everything that God gives
us is mediated it's mediated and it you
know it's mediated through matter
it is it is God's energy is not
amorphous it doesn't fly around and we
kind of catch it it's mediated to us
with great specificity
and most often through other people
and it's it's uh you know the best
counselors are the people who have gone
through the things themselves and worked
it out and then they give what they have
received to to the younger man
and so masculinity
masculinity is is is is coming into
self-knowledge again of who you are and
who God created you to be
so so it's self-knowledge but it's also
purpose
a man needs that it is
um realized and actualized in communion
with other men so true masculinity is is
a man who is on his journey with God in
a journey of self-discovery
self-disciplined towards the work that
God has called him to do whatever that
work might be
I tell the young guys they say the most
exhilarating Journey you can you can go
on is the Journey of self-discovery they
really like that they really like that
but what is the Christian walk you know
it's the discovery of God but the
discovery of God and then the discovery
of ourselves so so that's what it is in
the interior life exterior life it is
the cultivation of virtue which means to
protect and provide that's what it means
hmm and how do you see this let's say
the relationship of the of masculinity
with the feminine in the in in the
church or in society how do you see
those things being related to each other
I believe that there's a fundamental
structure in in in creation and
um you know I went to Denmark as you
know very very secular country all of
Northern Europe is
and um
and my takeaway my personal takeaway I
gave a lot and I received a lot
and one of the things that I I received
and I'm going to start speaking on this
more clearly is that uh
assert that the world is patriarchal
just assert it okay and and because what
I was doing is when I talked about
patriarchy I always had the arguments of
the detractors in the back of my mind
and I would tailor what I said to answer
the arguments the attractions and I came
away saying no no no no no no don't do
that the world is
structurally patriarchal because God is
father
and so that means that that male and
female have their own unique
contributions
they do
but there is an ordering to this
and the ordering is this and I can feel
it inside me right there's always that
tendency to self-center because you know
what the culture is thinking and how
they're going to react but that men have
to be men so women can be women mm-hmm
and that's a difficult thing to say
because a lot of women will object to
that but the the nature of their
objection is is is one that is caused by
by the collapse of masculinity in the
broader culture I think if men become
men
then women will find their way as well
so so the relationship is the
relationship is and this goes deep and I
can't say I understand it all but I
think about it a lot
but you know out of the Prospero which
is the theotokos it's the matter it's
the material Right comes the lamb who is
Christ in the Chalice it's the body and
blood of Christ but the body and blood
come from the theodos
all right so there's a complementarity
and and and a deep deep interdependence
between male and female in all of the
creation
really is but to to to think about these
things that's as far as I'm going to go
because the rest of what I have is just
speculation I'm not really ready to talk
about it but but to except for this
point to think of these questions
outside of of political categories and
cultural polemics
is very difficult
it's very difficult we have to recover
something that we have lost
we have to recover something that we
have lost male and female in the in the
creation has to do with matter and
meaning
it does you need both you need matter to
reveal the meaning
you meet you need meaning to give matter
its purpose and so it it it it it can
fulfill its to tidy illogical aim right
and and
it's wrapped up in that somehow Jonathan
but I'm waiting for you to work on it
I think that you've got the basics right
you know there's a sense in which
the for sure in the church the the the
the first thing to understand is that of
course human beings are not just their
their gender you know there's an aspect
in which we can we can go beyond like
what is it I mean the notion that Christ
says that you know in Christ there is no
male female like that is absolutely true
but there's also an aspect to which we
are gendered and in the respect that we
are gendered then we do manifest certain
realities in the world so it's important
first of all it's important to make that
distinction because sometimes when we
talk about men and women people can
think we're just reducing it to human
beings to their gender it's like no
we're not but we're also not pretending
as if that's not a way in which the
world is laying itself out and the way
in which the world is is it's a filling
filling the world with his glory is
through this this beautiful relationship
between male and female and so you're
right the the the feminine is the one
let's talk about Max and feminine in
general mostly because then it's not
just about human beings and their gender
but the feminine is this space and
that's why the theotokos is is presented
to us as in all those images you know
the ark the temple all the the images of
that which sustained from below that
holds or that gives body the mountain
the latter you know everything that
supports and then then the the male the
masculine let's say manifests itself as
the seed as the meaning as the you know
the the top of the mountain at the place
where things Heaven and Earth kind of
come together and so you see that all
through the all through the imagery that
is that is there in the Old Testament
and in the New Testament so I had the
relationship between head and body and
in some ways let's say in spiritually we
are all
we are all feminine in relationship to
God like we are all called to become the
bride of Christ and that that doesn't
that doesn't so at that level there's no
issue like it doesn't bother me to think
that I'm the bride of Christ but I also
have this other this aspect of myself
which is gendered in the world and in
that aspect I am I am
I am masculine I'm a man and I have to
play the role that that that uh that
entails which is as Christ says you know
to the idea of the the head of the
family that type of imagery which is
this reflection of the role that Christ
plays in regards to the church so these
are the things that are very culturally
they're very difficult for people to
understand but that's that's the way
with in which the the pattern kind of
it's a I I use the word fractal a lot
where it it's it happens at every level
of reality and in in yourself you also
have that relationship you could say
there's an aspect of you like the the
your body has a certain aspect which is
more feminine and there's an aspect of
you the meaning making part which is
more masculine and those relationships
happen even within yourself you know
it's it's a there's a
let's say
there's a part of you that the part of
you which is which sustains the meaning
which is which is equivalent to
let's say the the feminine in in every
other way let's say yeah
well it's it's real interesting I see
that's my answer because I get asked
well why do we have female priests I
think that's where the answer lies
because if you have a female priest you
have a symbolic collapse because in the
Chalice you have the body and by the
blood of Christ in the female body you
have the creative prowess of creation of
New Life men don't create like from
their bodies women do yeah okay so if a
woman is holding the Chalice right and
the Chalice contains the body and blood
of Christ but the body and blood come
from the theotokos because it's a
theotokos who gave the logos his human
nature and makes salvation possible on
that level right a male especially would
look at would look at the woman
and the chalice and I think you have a
collapse you have a collapse of meaning
right and the distinction between what
we're trying to Define here between and
the the material world and and and the
world of meaning
all right it collapses and so a male
priesthood actually is a preventative
against that kind of a collapse it holds
together the distinctives the binary
distinctives okay that are necessary
within the very within the operation of
the world within the operation of of
society
and um remove that and what happens and
we see that we're getting into cultural
polemics here a little bit but we see
that in the churches that have adopted a
female priesthood within 10 years
they're into all sorts of sexual
confusion yeah no but I think it's
important to mention because you know 20
years ago 30 years ago 50 years ago we
only had the promise where people were
saying oh we need we need equality we
just need this to happen female priests
it's the future you know it's it's the
the further Revelation it's the further
feeling of the holy spirit all these
arguments that they had and so it's like
okay some Churches did it but now we
have the fruit so let's look at the
fruits so so for we can see what the
fruits are and we can see the churches
that have done that what happens to the
to the church itself how it how it how
it falls into confusion falls into
revolutionary thinking it has this this
type of of a of of a revolutionary
approach to reality itself up to the
point where the bishop here of the
Anglican Church she she was the first
female bishop and she'd made a speech
where she says you know I'm paraphrasing
but she says something like now is the
time for us to reach up and grasp
Divinity for ourselves and you're
thinking Eve no not again yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah the quit is happening like it
just doesn't take long before the the
pattern sets itself up again really fast
it's yeah yeah yeah and I understand
that you know that revolutionary
thinking is inevitable you know what it
is it's just the desacralization of
Christian cultural categories that's
really what it is I get can't go any
other way remove Christ from it right
the categories still remain at least in
Chris Christendom or the memory of the
categories let's put it that way right
that's the period we're in right now so
it can only go revolutionary but this is
a kind of a revolutionary myself but I
think in a good way I think the most
I've been telling people this the last
few weeks especially I said you know
we're really going to have to get to a
point where we rebuild culture
that's what's going to happen this is
probably going to have to play out these
things do and then they die of spiritual
exhaustion the problem is I don't say
that lightly because there's a lot of
Carnage along the way there really is I
mean and the suffering
the suffering is real
two points on that but what I want to
say is that I think I've already started
it right by by bringing restoration to
these young men
and and I'm starting it now it's much
more important than kind of winning the
culture wars yeah start rebuilding
culture now because that's what's going
to be needed in 10 or 15 years do it now
and that's what part of this work is and
then my second point I forgot Jonathan
but it'll come back to me
but you're but I think that that's the
right approach because there's a sense
in which the darker things get the more
light will shine brightly and so you
know if if you have men who are examples
of loving positive
self-sacrificial masculinity with
authority though you know not just that
we have the sense that self-sacrifice
and and love just means being weak
that's not what it means that's not what
it meant in the case of Christ who is
constantly you know reproaching his I
mean Christ is not a soft figure but
he's not constantly you know like
snapping back at his disciples but he
was willing to die for them and die for
for for all those around him so this is
what I this is what I tell my Protestant
catech humans you know what I'll I'll
ask him well why did why did Christ die
and on the cross and they'll they'll
they'll tell me Well to forgive us of
our sins I said well wait a second there
was forgiveness of sins before Christ
came there was even baptism before
Christ came the baptism of John was for
the remission of sins so why did he
really come and they're stumped and I
say he came to conquer the devil we call
him the Conqueror right and it removes
kind of this this this feminized gloss
that is over American Civil religion
right removes and look at him and
realize that the crucifixion on the
cross was a voluntary self-sacrifice for
what reason to free us from the tyranny
of the devil and I contend that what I
call the Matrix behind it is demonic
power and the Demonic power is to to
Blind Men to their own manhood and their
masculinity so go going back to
pornography in particular I I believe it
comes from the depth of hell
to to to to
destroy the characters of young men
before they can become before they
realize who they are and what they can
become right so there's a spiritual
warfare to this now what what what ties
it in and this is the point I forgot
is that you said when darkness increases
the light is greater that is so true I
see the grace of God so powerful
especially in the lives of these young
men and when they need encouragement I
tell them because it's true and I see it
over and over again no one desires their
healing more than God God is on their
side
um they've never heard that
they don't believe it they're beat down
but it's objectively true the grace that
flows to help them overcome and to help
them
to be stronger is so consistent and it's
so strong that I just know it's coming
say the prayer it's coming I believe
that that this path and this work is is
directed ultimately by our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ and it's absolutely
necessary that it gets done so
consequently part of the reason too for
the Brotherhood is that I want to build
resources to get to other priests that's
what I want to do because a lot of
priests now you mentioned it at the
beginning
where you know the churches are just
being are filled up with catech humans
well they're they're being filled up
primarily with the young men that's
right my contention by the way with the
woman questions when the guys get
themselves together the women will
follow that's my prediction right
but we don't know what to do
you know I've spent the last 10 years
doing it a little longer than that so
I've learned a few things but I'd like
to pass this knowledge along because
they're because
it's new it's something new and we we
have to learn how to do it and that's
another reason for
the Brotherhood you know Jonathan
um it's different this time around
because you know when I first became a
priest was like 20 20 years ago 25 years
ago
um you know it was basically
um my catechism was okay what was your
religious tradition and then you kind of
tailored the catechism to that to show
them where Orthodoxy was different I I
call it now you know Orthodoxy and 10
easy lessons basically it was that but
but my catechism changed once I started
dealing with these guys and was
basically how to walk how to find Christ
and how to walk with them and the
history and all that came later the
theology was fleshed out through their
own direct experience with him and the
inner transformation that they
experienced it's much more I would say
the catechism is much more existential
experiential that type of thing not so
much here but a lot here because these
guys and this is the difference who come
into the church now they come in out of
out of their pain
it's their pain that that compels them
to look upward
and then they start going on YouTube and
they find you and they find all this
Orthodox stuff right and that's what
brings them into the Orthodox Church
yeah
and they come in specifically for
healing
and so how are you going to scale what
you're doing I guess because now it's
mostly you being like a mentor you know
kind of father to these young men and so
how do you see this scaling in terms of
having these brotherhoods in other
places well I'm not building a a an
organization top down and really broad
okay basically what I'm doing is is
doing virtually what I hope to see done
in real time and locally
so we're getting information out there
we're learning as we go we're going to
start classes where where guys sign up
for and they're going to have to pay for
it okay you're gonna have some skin in
the game all right and and where there
are certain areas in their life they
want to improve on this and that we'll
have classes on it accountability groups
so you know maybe 10 guys and they hold
each other to account
right we'll build that out and all this
information that we have that we're just
going to give it away if a priest wants
to do this in a local church fine if a
bun if guys want to get together and do
it on themselves fine okay it's too it's
to generate a movement for the creation
of brotherhoods because guys crave
Brotherhood they crave the love of a
brother that's how we're going to scale
it out
yeah I mean it's a it's a great idea
because
that used to exist I mean it it's so
funny because it used to exist where
they were these groups clubs mail-only
type organizations where men uh were
together by themselves in in groups and
would just have this bonding and it's
funny because those all those groups
were attacked systematically by the
feminists non-stop for Gen for like
decades and decades you know saying that
it's sexist and you should have women in
these groups and they all succeeded so
all the groups are gone and now it's
super interesting because now you go to
a gym and there's the women's only
section or now you go to it you go to
this thing you have women only clubs and
you're thinking what what what happens
wait wait a minute how did this how did
this happen you know like you're
realizing that it's important to have
spaces in which women only can interact
with each other so yeah we need those
for men too now they're all destroyed so
yeah so thank God for something like
what you're doing because yeah we're
going to rebuild it that's what we're
going to do and I see it in the lives of
men you know I you know I go and speak
and and one of my my conditions is no
women now it's not that this is a secret
society these these these talks get
recorded they're public right but I've
got to speak only to men because when if
there's a woman there it changes it
changes everything yeah and I have to
think it's the same with women yeah
right yeah it's not it's not it's not
it's a it's not wrong that it changes
that it should change it but it also
means that some subjects or some
Dynamics are not possible as soon as the
genders are mixed and some you know it's
like if you have men and women in the
same space and it will create a certain
type of dynamic which which can which is
just neutral it's neither good nor bad
it depends what you want but some things
that you would want to have only men
because you want to you want to foster a
certain type of of dynamic a
relationship or pattern of of
interrelationship that you can't have if
there's a woman there and and women now
the feminists are going to draw and
quarter me for this
but they're wrong and what I'm saying is
Right women
I just have to declare it I have to I
have to stop being apologetic about it
okay women want strong men
feminine women
they want their women to be feminine
they want their women to be women and
men and women want their men to be men
okay let's just say it all right and
there's this this collapse of of the
sexist into kind of this this this
uniform
um
totalitarian egalitarianism because
that's what it becomes right that's just
horrible it's death to the soul it's
death to the soul yeah but what's
interesting actually father it's not as
it's even more complex than what you're
saying because because the desire for
women the desire that men have for women
to be feminine the desire for for women
that women want men to be masculine
because there's this totalitarian
egalitarian you know Fusion of
everything it also creates strange
parasitic
extreme male figures and so what you end
up having is you have a weird parasitic
version of of hyper masculinity which
becomes popular and things like gangster
rap or you know 50 Shades of Gray all
these images yeah of hyper masculine
violent you know dangerous men become
idealists and then you have these insane
kind of horror you know Pros almost like
prostitute images of of hyper feminine
uh you know broken down images and they
become extremely popular so on the one
hand you have this idea that we ought to
be the same and we ought to be exactly
the same and then you have these these
figures that look like like
caricature of a caricature of a
caricature of what a man and a woman is
yeah it becomes freakish the distortions
become freakish because if everything is
is is is melded together it's the only
thing that you can see yeah it's the
only indication of of Distinction left
which still
conversely affirms that those that that
the fundamental distinction the binary
is true because
how else could you see it if your soul
wasn't longing for that that that
particular distinction it goes back to
the structure of things again and
there's a matter in which you know
Christianity for example will mediate
and will let's say tame the extreme
desire for
the extremes let's say and we'll bring
it into something that is purposeful but
as soon as you if you take that away
then it's not as if those opposites go
away it's that they become they become
like you said they become insane they
become insane caricatures that are
ridiculous yes it becomes freakish yeah
freakish it's a great deal I mean this
is this is how when you try and
understand how is it that people get
caught up in these perversions that's
how it's really Distortion if we can see
human ontology in the way that same
Maximus the the uh Confessor describes
it which is kind of a repudiation that
man is innately evil and the whole kind
of calvinistic anthropology that swept
through the west and it's still largely
there I think that those cultural that
those ideas formed in some of these
cultural presuppositions that bring us
in that freakish direction if you can
see it in the way in human anthropology
like in the Orthodox understanding in in
particularly same Maximus a Confessor
you can also begin to understand how the
this freakishness emerge emerges and how
people get caught up in these vices
there's there's a certain there's a
certain logic to it you know it's it's
the logic of distortion let's call it
that yeah it's and it's it's we we tend
I use the word parasitic I like that
John traviki has that word parasitic a
parasitic process which is the idea that
it's a desire that's good in itself but
when it gets disconnected from its true
purpose it starts to turn on itself you
know out of Pride out of this self
looking back at itself and so it becomes
a caricature exactly it becomes a kind
of freakish version of what the the what
it what's what's actually making it
exist which is a good that it's supposed
to be aligned to and so then it all
becomes these weird kind of yeah
freakish caricatures and I always see
the benevolence of God in there and the
I really do
um because I'm confronted sometimes with
things so that people have done or what
they're they're entrapped in right a
vice vice is really real and a vice can
can really hold a grip over a person's
soul
but that can be broken the vice can be
broken and the Soul can be healed
because and this is the remarkable thing
it's just it just really is it gives me
so much hope
because God is good because God seeks to
pray
and heal the person they're synonymous
freedom and healing are synonymous right
now that even a person caught up in
something like that and can't find his
way out can find his way out through
Christ and be restored to what is
natural be restored to what is natural
that's Orthodoxy it's just beautiful
well thanks father I think I think
that's a great way to to end the
discussion I I really appreciate the
work you're doing and I'll ask everybody
you know to go check out the the same
page to his Brotherhood the website
we'll put a link in the description and
father hunts thanks for your work and
and uh keep going we we will be watching
yeah and uh sent to you Jonathan keep it
up we need you we need you you do a lot
for us so thank you very much thanks
brother okay God bless you